it's the Russian claims that there is no
push for a regime change but it's very
clear earlier on in the war they were
quoted as saying they were looking to
help liberate Ukraine from the uh from
the regime in place so the question is
now why is it changed for Putin it's
evident the war is not going the way he
had planned at all it's clear that
Russia is having to revise his
objectives it looks most likely this
claim is more for a domestic audience in
Russia than it is for us so no real
change but I certainly wouldn't expect
any uh any um letting up in the campaign
if Valencia is still under a lot of
pressure and a lot of danger and we've
seen it with her son which was liberated
just last week but already people there
are being advised to leave what's going
on there yeah there's a lot of talk
because of the blackouts because as the
winter approaches life is becoming
really difficult picture of the some of
the evacuations happening just from last
night
um and the Russians are doing a
devastating impact across the whole of
the energy infrastructure across Ukraine
and and the ukrainians are offering free
um uh free opportunities for the
civilians to evacuate
um part of the challenge though question
is why focus on Harrison because the
whole country has been hit by the same
challenges part of that uh the answer to
that is that um whilst the Russians have
been ejected from Harrison they are just
the other side of the donipo river so
they are literally sitting within
artillery range of Housing and that
means they're still a major threat it's
also the ukrainians are clearly having a
go at have they paused or are they going
to continue their offensive if they
continue their offensive out to the
north around the top of zapritia across
potentially in
damn and also down to the kinburn spit
Peninsula and the ukrainians have
already admitted that they are already
mounting operations onto that spits and
Peninsula that would seem from a
military perspective really difficult to
do because it's quite small and exposed
why were they going to do that because
that is means the ukrainians control
both mouths of the donipro river and
also means the michelia and helson ports
are also secure and finally what about
these Brimstone missiles that the UK has
sent
um we've sent them today how useful
might they be to the ukrainians yeah
Brimstone is a really good example of a
British very high-tech weapon that's
part of the latest package of Aid that's
going from the British government
earlier in the war Brimstone one was
sent off Brimstone 2 have now been sent
off this weapon only ended service in
2016 so it's one of the most latest
we've got it's got double the range of
its predecessor we understand it's
around 40 kilometers dual mode which
means that these um windows at the front
can either pick up laser energy and then
Target themselves or they've actually
got a radar in as well and then their
memory banks they've got a whole load of
Russian military equipment and they can
prioritize the right equipment they're
going for they can even hit moving
targets as well ferociously expensive
175 000 pounds a missile they've had
fight about 750 of these so far in
operations more generally and they've
got a success rate of something like 99
also importantly unlike the Russians
doing this sort of blanket bombing the
these things provide Precision effects
and massively reduce Collateral Damage I
think particularly interest as well is
when the early phase this war when
Ukraine were on the defense Russian
tanks were attacking they needed
anti-tech weapons of short range now
Ukraine is going on to the offensive the
Russian tanks the further away they need
weapons with longer range and that's
exactly what this it does but for me
it's a really excellent example of
British high-tech weapons making a
decisive difference in the campaign